That did it.
Oh my God, Wahooo!
Wahoo! It's a me, a Mercio!
Kahaio! It's a Mercio!
Let's play the Mario RPG! Wahoo!
Hahahaha!
Oops! Oops! Oops! Oops!
Things are knocking over! Stop moving!
Okay, okay, here we go.
Mercio!
I'm gonna walking on my Italian, okay?
Son of a bitch!
Hahahaha!
And mine!
Thank you, Slice Saber, for remembering for one month.
Sorry I left the cage in touch-grass.
That's fine. Are you happy after you touch-grass?
Okay, and that's all that matters.
Wahoo! Okay, let's go play!
Let's go play, everyone!
Ah, I'm sorry, I finally remember!
It's a lot! It's a lot!
I can go through a chimney, right? No?
I totally forgot what we were supposed to do.
I remember everyone got kidnapped.
And now we have to find them.
Oh yeah, we have to recover the stolen star.
Is there anything else I need to do in the village?
Just double-checking.
Good to see you again. Do you have a chance to accumulate many frog coins?
Let's see ya.
Oh, right. Shit! I need this. Yes.
Ah, I don't have that many frog coins! I need that one too.
Oh my goodness, I need to go get that one. Hold on.
We're gonna do a funky thing.
We're gonna do the worst, and...
I'm gonna...
Where was that place that had, like, the...
The waterfall? Is it this one? No.
This one? I wanna play it again.
I can try to look again if I'm a trampoline. It only costs 30 coins.
Simpa!
Yes! Okay, we're doing it.
Night hop on!
Wahoo!
Okay, we're gonna get at least two more coins.
Okay.
This is the minus river course!
Wanna crash cars in it? Yeah, I forgot. I forgot.
Go start at the top of the falls. Use left to move right...
Left or right and score coins.
Press B to make a headway a little against the pool.
Along the way, there are a few holes. As to what will happen, we'll just keep that a surprise.
Off you go!
I need my green coins.
Green? Green? Green? Green green?
Green?
Want green? Green?
Green? No green.
Wahoo! Green! Green! Green!
I want green.
And green coins.
Wait, am I done?
Oh, shit. I forgot about this part.
Now for the bear jump event!
Need some pointers? Yeah.
Time to jump and grab coins along the way!
Oh, shit. I hate this one.
Jump on to the next bear before they collide!
There was no green.
Miss it, new change course!
Looks like you're hitting something on your way!
Almost forgot to tell you, leap over the fish that pop up or you'll lose coins!
Ah!
Son of a bitch!
Don't you dare!
Shut up, I'm a gamer!
Son of a bitch! I knew you were coming from behind too!
Ah!
Seventeen coins, thank you.
Wow, it really, I didn't have anything. I didn't have it.
I can't believe I didn't have it.
Wait, get back here. That's it, we're gonna fight.
Where am I supposed to go again?
I totally forgot where I was supposed to go! Tee-hee!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much, Kisignal Delta!
Delta, uh, 7-9.
For gifting 50, 50 memberships.
Thank you!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you, Jamdrop196 for the 134 Sufa.
Hi, Kohai, any interest in the Ace Attorney games?
Yes, but I've already played them all.
Recently.
So therefore,
I don't think I'll pick it up
unless maybe I'll play the Miles Edgeworth game.
Since I haven't played that one.
That was only available for limited time.
I don't think it was ever released here at all.
I can't remember was I supposed to go to Merrymore?
That feeling when you totally forgot exactly what you were supposed to do.
And when...
Spot with the big red, like, Kohai.
Oh, okay, hold on.
I'm so hungry, I wish I could have a caramel cookie!
How much are you selling your shit again for?
Like fireworks, I'm working on my very own invention right now.
I only got the sparklers now, mine giving up.
One buy one for 500 coins.
Ah, how much is it?
500 coins is a lot, right?
And I don't have a lot.
This one?
Red dot, red dot.
Which one was the red dot?
Red flag.
My mistake, reading comprehension isn't there.
Oh, it's still here, okay.
It's still here, okay.
So they are somewhere around here still.
Reading comprehension, that doesn't mean a thing to me.
I can't read, that sign won't stop me.
I was speaking of...
Signs that won't stop me.
Speaking of signs that won't stop me.
Did you notice that I got the gamer's stops?
Uh, being working, yes.
It's here.
The special banner for the special cold.
That's right.
That's right, it's a me, Masio.
It's a sponsored by the gamer's stops.
Please use the cold, Masi.
Five, ten percent off your order.
And if there's enough orders, I can get a waifu cup.
And maybe a flavor.
Hee hee.
Which is really cool.
By the way, gamer's stops are sending me a PR package.
So I can try it out too.
And so I'll let you know what's the best flavor.
A blade's...
It's beautiful, hold on.
A blade's laid, what's taking it so long?
We need to get out of here.
Oh, this is just great.
Mario caught up with us.
One thing we can do now.
Only one thing to do now.
Although we may rest a little.
We'll have to swim for it.
Not so fast.
That stars a gift to me.
Senpai.
Thank you, D-man.
Zero, three.
Zero, two.
Two.
Uh, so used.
For remembering for one month.
Uh, so used code mercy to get 10% off gamer's stops?
Yes.
That's exactly what you're supposed to do.
Please use it.
In fact, every single member in VLR has a code.
So you should use your code.
So you should use everyone's code six times.
So order six times.
Hold on.
Let me try this again.
This one's a...
That's so fast there.
That stars a gift to me, mate.
Mario.
You spineless dogs have no code of honor.
Honor.
I'll make you walk the plank.
Johnny, maybe you should leave Mario the pleasure
of wrapping things up here.
He...
I guess we'll have to take our disguises off now.
Group formation.
Ah, blinding.
Oh my gosh, you look like that one guy from...
Actually, what do you remind me of?
I'm trying to remember.
I can use a trip and move now.
Hold on.
Clown car barrage.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Aw, so cute.
Yes.
Can't block.
Okay.
Max mushroom.
We'll give myself the mushroom.
And then we'll do a special.
Super jump, super fireball.
Sure.
Ah!
To your eyes, Poisonful.
Actually, I think your attack is better.
Ah, shit.
Ah!
No!
You should pick me up.
I'll have to.
I'll have four left.
Thanks.
Gotta free me.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Let's try...
Super fireball again.
Or jump.
Let's try jump.
Super jump?
I can try super jump.
Ah!
I'm stuck in it!
You use most party energy, I'd say.
No.
Mid mushroom.
There.
Use the mushroom.
Thank you.
He's gonna fucking die at this rate.
Why can't I block it?
Ah!
Okay, let's switch.
There you go.
Ah, fuck it.
Just attack.
If you know Whirl.
Attack some enemy.
Sure.
Well, I am so bad at timing, never mind.
Mirage attack.
Fuck it, just do the beam.
Yo!
Whee!
Please be poisoned.
Fuck!
Ah!
My gaming!
My gaming sucks!
I'm not a gamer!
Why did I think I could game?
Ah!
Okay.
I can do it.
Let's do honey sheerle.
Ugh.
Ah, come on.
Am I just a lousy?
Yeah.
Okay.
Switch him out with Siege.
BP time.
Ah, just attack.
I gotta get better at this somehow.
Ah!
Okay, maybe I can zoink him out.
Is it sheep?
Ah!
It's not looking good.
It's not looking good, Senpai.
Not looking good, Senpai.
Here is my thing.
Pick me up.
Okay, maybe you can do an attack up.
Me?
Am I supposed to just tank this?
Okay.
Okay, let's hug Mario.
Good.
I need a therapy myself!
Hug myself!
Hug yourself.
Hug me.
Okay.
Gonna need more FP.
Can I switch her out?
Ah, everyone else is fucking dead!
Senpai!
Thank you, Seltzam, for remembering.
You got this, Kai.
Thank you!
I'll try my best.
Well, hugs are powerful.
We're just gonna deal with it.
Bitch slap.
Ah!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't realize they would be so strong.
Does Peach get to have gear on?
I might have not put any gear on her.
Thank you, Rai-Ramathal.
Thank you for remembering for one month.
Oh, I almost forgot this.
Never forget again.
Come on.
I'm losing this.
I'm losing this so badly.
I made a mushroom from my shelf.
Hmm.
Here, use a mid mushroom.
Ah, you need therapy.
Oh, his FP's gone.
Yay!
Don't heal!
Oh, that did it a lot more.
Okay.
Just attack.
Yes!
This is looking possible!
How did we do it?
This is my star!
I made the video lose so much
that I could not use an attack anymore.
Suki!
Say,
you must have been a breeze knocking down Spearie, huh?
No.
By the way,
my parents say they saw a huge axe flying across the sky.
Probably one of Smithy's nasty friends.
Go get him, pal.
Sorry, that was totally the wrong accent.
Well, my girls are failing on me.
Wait.
Err, matey.
Well, my girls are failing on me,
so I'll be heading back down,
dropping whenever you have time, okay?
Your true mate,
Jonathan Johnny Jones.
Yes!
Whee!
Is everyone alive?
Phew!
Thank you so much!
I've had enough of this crap dirty old place like this!
Hey, fella,
you got us on a buying piece, bro!
Wait, hey, fella,
you got us on a buying piece, brother.
It was mighty unpleasant here.
Thanks for helping us out.
Thank you!
Ah, thanks a lot!
Be sure to stop by!
Yeah, stop by my!
Thank you for freeing us.
I've got to get back to work now,
but stop by in the end and see you there.
Ah, Mario.
Thank you for saving our little town of Seaside.
Being the most important person in the village,
it was inevitable that I would be tortured.
Are you immune to the tickle tortures, Mario?
Ah, yes, this is for you.
Please take it.
Received one coin!
One coin, Senpai.
I'm so...
I'm so relieved
that all of the townspeople were all right in the end.
Can you believe he just didn't kidnap him?
He had to nerve to lock him up, too?
Me and my minions would never put a stunt like that!
Really?
I seem to recall certain someone kidnapping me not too long ago.
Grr!
But no one got hurt, right?
Well, so all's well that ends well.
Ha ha!
Come on, let's scram already.
The mode in here is bad for my sensitive nostrils.
Here, here.
We should see the sites in town now that it's back to normal.
Maybe someone in here can point us to the next art piece.
Tickle torture.
Well, if I didn't tickle torture him so much,
how much would it have been?
Yangster from Tadpole Pawn recently moved in here for good.
If you don't let the elder get tortured,
he'll give you a flower box instead.
But my sadism!
Okay, out here there aren't many people passing through,
so it gets awful only sometimes.
Please rest up.
Only cost you 15 coins.
Sure.
Well, rest up.
Okay.
Woohoo!
Whee!
Yeah.
I gotta get a lot of stuff now.
Okay, let's see what else they have.
Let's just say.
Welcome to Beatles Are Us!
We run a Beatles business here.
Want an explanation?
Yes!
Huh.
That sounds like fun.
I think that's fun.
Oh, they're so small they don't even look past the counter.
Welcome to my living shop.
Okay, let's see what we got.
Koopa shell.
Punch glove.
Super hammer.
Paratrooper shell.
Lucky hammer.
Symbols?
Womp gloves.
Ribbit stick.
Finger shot.
Handgun.
Double punch.
Shake chomp.
Curly glove.
Slap glove.
Parasol.
Please come and browse!
Okay, let's see.
I've got happy pants for you.
Sailor pants.
Like a cape.
Happy cape.
Sailor cape.
Yeah, okay, they're all already clipped.
It's a hurly glove?
Okay.
I got it.
Hi, Mario.
You got a lot of health food in our store.
You've got to treat your body right.
Yeah, I need it.
I am out of like pick-me-ups.
Okay, cleansing juice, party cleanse.
A lot of pick-me-ups and I need...
...a lot of pick-me-ups.
I need...
Mushroom boy.
You know that hidden amongst the regular mushrooms are some special ones.
Unreal, huh?
I'll give you items in return for those special mushrooms.
You've got to taste them to find out what kind they are,
so I'll take a nibble first.
I'll think for a special mushroom,
but even if it isn't,
I think I'll get a meal out of it.
Do you have any mushrooms?
Yeah.
Okay, far out munch munch.
Oh, this one's a berry mushroom.
I'll give you a maple syrup.
Oh boy, I'm stuffed.
Alright, like this is unreal.
It's a ripping mushroom.
Rock candy.
Oh boy, I'm stuffed.
I don't know...
How do I know how many mushrooms I have?
Hello there, you were so brave to rescue us,
and I'm so thankful.
Listen, maybe it's time you thought more about what you wear.
Festerizing is a big business these days.
See anything you like here?
Zoom shoes and soot.
These look really good, but...
I don't have the money.
That was just a regular mushroom.
Thanks for the snack.
Hello?
Alright.
Wait.
My bad.
I need to go back.
Hold on.
I forgot the other house on the hill.
Here.
Ariel, if it's a star you're looking for,
I may be able to help you.
A four-
Side of land and is a town made up of reformed monsters.
Mouse came by the other day
and overheard them bolstering by a star of theirs.
I don't know exactly where this town is located,
but if you follow the road, you get there.
Okay.
Three, four monsters.
To help their extra nice.
Have you seen the sea before?
It sure is vast.
Definitely worth the trip.
Now you want to go through the ocean again?
Where's the shed?
I have a key for a shed.
Oh, wait.
This is the shed.
I got the key for that.
Wow.
I'm stupid.
I got it.
Oh, same.
Look at this.
There you go.
That's rude.
You hooked on the princess.
You son of a bitch.
Level up.
Yay.
I think Bowser's physical, right?
Yeah.
Shogun, huh?
Okay.
I don't like the way you look.
Yay.
Thanks for the attack up.
Okay.
Die.
Shogun.
She knows how to show his gun.
Yeah.
Okay.
One more.
Come on.
I don't like that flower.
It has lips.
It...
It looks disturbed me.
Oh, I really did.
Okay.
Oh, man.
No, Gino!
Okay.
Oh!
You son of a bitch!
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
That was kind of evil.
It's up there.
How do I get up there?
Okay.
Fuck.
Why are there so many of you?!
Bear us all.
Okay.
Bitch slap.
Hmm.
Wait.
Is that a mini Mario?!
Just needed Peach to go away for a little bit.
Mario reached level 13.
I'll say physical.
So!
No!
Ah!
He's doing Mario!
Actually, I thought it was just a Mario doll!
Step pie!
Thank you for the immense funny boy!
I suck at this.
Just attacking Mario.
Cowardly.
Ah!
Come on!
No!
Why are you literally?!
Why do you die all the time?!
How do you get one shot every single time?!
Ah!
This is hell.
Fuck!
Never mind.
I'm fucking screwed.
Nope, everyone's fucking dead.
Oh hi!
Did you know you can block attacks?!
I've been trying to block attacks.
I just don't have the skills to do that!
I just don't have the skills to actually do it!
To pull it off!
We are now going to grind levels because I suck.
That was a place to get good stuff.
I have no money!
Just like real life!
It all goes to bills.
I also want beetles.
The fee is 101.
I want up the beetles too.
I want to get up the beetles too.
Oh, I have that already.
I have all those items.
Let me go back to my box.
Maybe I can pick up some items from my box.
Maybe I had some stuff in my box.
Oops, not that one.
Wait, I have things that aren't equipped?
Let me go back to my box.
Ailing pants.
I think we're good there.
Give me my stuff.
Take max of everything.
Thank you.
Go through my accessories.
Give us a sec.
Booster's charm.
I thought booster's charm was good.
Nurturing.
Booster's charm.
Use safety ring.
Safety ring.
Booster's charm is better for Bowser.
Some shoes.
Booster's charm.
Another safety badge.
Because you are paper.
Doomshoes are great for Gino.
Okay, thank you, senpais.
Boom.
Good.
I wonder if I'll be okay now.
Star Hill? We'll train at Star Hill then?
Let's do some grinding!
Whatever, we'll go into any of them.
RPGs grind!
Get over here!
We are now.
Die.
Are you the other star me?
What a terrible move!
What a terrible move! Migraine!
Get over here!
I can use recovery items in the field like X.
I can use all of these? Yes!
Get over here!
Alright!
Thank you.
You need magic.
Get over here!
Holy shit, it went down!
Let's see!
It throws a bone!
Let's go!
Sure. Where's Yoshi?
Yay!
Yeah, Yoshi!
Yeah, my eyes are so good.
Hey, where's the play that I came from?
Oh shit.
There you go.
Okay.
Fuck.
Yay!
Dino is a magic guy, right?
Yeah.
Fuck.
There you go.
How did I get back out?
You don't remember how to get back out?
Oh, this one.
Me and...
Isn't Johnny's ship a better grind spot?
You're probably right.
And I'm already lost.
This one?
No, I already looked at that one.
Here's the other one.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
How did I get out of here?
Come here, Leaf!
There you go.
Thank you.
The ship then?
Okay.
Wait, is this the same sign?
Yeah.
I go through here.
I totally forgot how to do this area.
Oh yeah, the mice.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Hi.
Maybe bells are...
Let me in.
That's a water thing, right?
Yeah!
Oops.
Okay.
I suck at this so bad.
Ah, he just drills!
Mario!
Come on.
Can I use Peach's power?
Oh, wait, is he okay?
You never mind, he's okay.
I love how we go through here.
He's grinding too.
It's like status effects wear off at the end of the battle.
This is Nocturne Mercy.
I'm mixing up my RPGs, this is what happens.
This is what happens when you've got like three RPGs running at the same time.
You've got Nocturne, I've got Wild Arms,
I've got Mario,
and I'm thinking about getting another one!
Oh gosh, he's so hot suddenly.
Okay.
The big blur of RPGs!
And I haven't touched Mario RPG in a hot second.
Hello, thank you.
Okay.
I just want him to like throw Mario around all the time.
Peach is a magic girl, right?
Oh, thank you!
Revive a pal!
Thank you!
Come back, revive a pal if it goes well.
Feel the...
Yes, she's a magic gal, right?
She's a magic gal.
You think we're at a good level?
Okay.
I'll go check what my level is now.
Can I actually... hold on.
How do I check their level?
13, 13, 13, 13, 13.
What do you think?
Okay.
Do we have enough frog coins now?
Alright, we have enough frog coins for the...
For the Confucius Frog.
Other Confucius Frog.
Okay.
I don't have enough!
I need one more!
I need one more.
Yeah.
I think the only thing I...
want are the Beatles RS.
It's kind of expensive.
Like, I don't know how much I have.
It's not that much.
We've got plenty of money.
Do you think I should get some Beatles RS?
Ah, sure.
Can you see some ID, please?
Everything looks fine!
All you just jumped a show ID!
Easy beat-a-locks. Good luck and happy hunting.
So, do I just go back to Booster's place?
Booster Tower?
Is there a hill?
There's no way there's Booster Hill, alright.
Booster's Pass and Booster Tower.
Oh, no wait, there's Booster Hill.
Wow, I'm stupid!
How do I catch these freaking Beatles?
Ready for Beatles RS?
Do you need instructions?
Yes!
Left, right, or jump?
Can't go forwards or backwards.
Right.
Touch the sniffsters or any of the barrel
and you'll fall back.
Oh, yeah, I remember!
That was really hard!
I remember this was really hard.
Oops!
I want a Beatles!
You can move, I'm doing better!
Fuck you!
I want a Beatles!
Congratulations, seven Beatles!
Hi, females, two males!
Yay!
Then I can go back here, right?
Be like,
Yeah meme!
Yeah, Beatles!
I thought we were just like, you know...
You made 105 coins!
Good doing business with ya!
Thank you!
Okay, we'll rest up again.
I actually took a nap
before streaming
and I was...
I told mama, wake me up!
And then she scared me
when she woke me up!
I'm not used to this new time, so...
Alright!
My timing's bad!
Dang it!
Hit me again!
Getting it!
I like him throwing Mario, it's great!
Raiders!
Sorry!
Who raided?
I missed it!
Hello, Salami, welcome to the stream!
What were you doing?
Sorry, I missed it!
That's a big spider.
I missed it and I was too busy gaming!
Welcome to the stream!
My name is Mercy Modis
from VLRS Gen 1 Indulge!
Nice to meet you!
Sorry!
I'm Masio!
Masio!
It's me, Masio!
Welcome to the stream!
I totally forgot!
I'm Masio!
Masio!
Welcome to the stream!
We are playing the Mario RPG!
How was the karaoke?
X, fire! Die first!
Okay, I'm getting it!
Slowly!
There you go!
Our nice circulation is...
The one weeb song!
That was really popular!
Stage up!
Oh yeah!
Wrong one! I wanted to hit the spider again!
Oh, thank you!
Actually, I got the one scan, that's okay.
No.
Kino beam!
Woohoo!
Son of a bitch!
I mean, sorry! Son of a page!
You can get in my shrooms!
I'm gaming, sort of!
I got one fraud coin!
I can go back!
I don't wanna!
Oops, sorry!
Yay!
Son of a beach!
I'm so glad they're hurting each other!
Aww, look at that!
You know, these geckos kind of remind me of scrawny!
Geckos, these geckos kind of look like scrawny, right?
Yay, level up Bowser!
Thank you, Bowser, for reaching level.
I think you're more physical.
Yeah, physical.
Oh, there we go.
Am I actually just supposed to, like, be here?
Racer!
Oh, I see where I was supposed to go.
And I failed, spectacularly!
I'll save these for later.
Shit.
Oh, it hit itself!
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
I'm a gamer!
Yeah, gaming!
Oh save part!
Save!
Wahoo! These guys look horrible!
Oh fuck.
How bad are these guys?
Stingers look pretty bad.
Oh thank goodness they died!
I don't like you flower!
Gaming, gaming, gaming!
I'll look like a picture of a lot of new people here!
Thank you!
Thank you for checking me out!
Wahoo!
Okay.
Maybe there's actually stuff over here.
Cool stuff.
Hidden stuff.
Secret stuff even.
Yes!
Flower tab!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Do I use all these?
Are these like, um, perma, perma, perma,
perma, flower tabs or perma, right?
Okay, okay.
Use them all!
What about flower jar?
That's perma too, right?
Flower jar is perma.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Hmm.
Bump.
Yeah.
You win!
Woo!
You're also physical, right, Mario?
Ultra jump!
Hmm.
Ah.
There's too many of them!
Wheeee!
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna try.
Hi.
Now I'm gonna just do the super jump again.
I'm gaming!
So, I'm such a gamer!
Snowy, a snowfall, man fell, fells full.
Hmm.
Okay, magic.
Does this mean I jump down?
Oh, hi!
Welcome to Skybridge!
It's a big tourist attraction here.
Yahoo!
Wanna challenge it?
Sure.
Okay, I need five coins from you.
You need an explanation?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
You can cross the Skybridge in one of three ways.
However, if you fall at any time, you'll lose.
Normal course, the blocks won't fall.
You can jump to the next block by tilting left button in the direction you're going,
then press B.
You get five coins for that.
A special course, jumping works the same as the normal course,
but the blocks will fall if you stand on them too long.
You'll get eight coins there.
An expert course, the block will fall and jumps are harder.
You'll get a fraud coin there.
On all the courses, you have to jump and avoid bullet guys.
And, of course, do you want normal, please?
Yahoo!
Good luck to ya!
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, like...
Ah!
Holy shit!
Going up?
I'll give you a boost to jump on top of me.
I don't want to.
Fuck you.
I'm cheating the system.
That cost me five coins, man!
I'm not going to jump on top of you.
Five coins, man!
Oh!
It's a mouse.
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
Yeah!
I haven't been here in a while.
I haven't been busy traveling along.
Are you heading to the Monstro Town by Vanitya?
Yeah!
Okay, listen up.
Look for the Whirl when the ants pop up and proceed after it.
You follow it and you'll find your way underground.
That's there.
Monstro Town is just around the corner.
I'll see you there.
Ants?
You want ants?
This is how you get ants.
The one with ants?
Oh, that one.
Come on.
Like this?
Is that what they're asking me to do?
Oh, shit.
Shit.
I'm so stupid.
I got the wrong one.
I got the wrong bitch.
Okay.
That was my bad.
Yeah.
Penal blast.
This beam hits awful.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Wait.
Wait, what was the instruction?
I don't get it.
Sorry, what was the instruction?
Oh.
Shit.
Ah, shit.
Oh, that was nice.
That's nice.
Shit.
Oh, sorry.
Did I go to the wrong one?
Did I go after this one?
Oi!
That's kind of mean.
Shit.
He jumped to the other hall.
These ants are cheating.
I don't even know which one it is.
This one?
Shit.
Oh, shit.
Yes!
Should I put Peach to have more magic?
Or more physical?
Maybe not physical?
Okay, magic it is then.
Ah.
Am I there?
Yeah.
Bowser, boo!
Hold up.
Alright, I can use the infield.
Not bad, I forgot.
Right.
Hold on, read the instructions.
Totally, totally blanked out.
Okay, is it here?
Oh.
Ah!
Crush your earth eruption hit a right after the rock pokes out.
Dillum Temple.
Rounded coins, this shortcut will take you back to the surface, no thanks.
You want your fortune told? It'll cost 50 coins.
I did the fortune yesterday.
Wait, should I?
Should I get my fortune told?
Someone will give me a star?
Hold on.
Ah.
Okay.
Behind the pox is past the springs.
Physical.
Oh.
Magic.
Here?
Lucky for a star, I'm selling 400 coins, are you interested?
That's a lot of coins, Senpai!
Okay.
Well, just two more.
Yay, grinding!
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Well, it's useless to get a once again when they're dead.
Magic.
Not gonna lie, the grind cost a lot of money.
Is there anything over here?
So, should I get my fortune told, Senpai?
Should I get my fortune told?
Yeah?
Be the face on the wall, hit any of them in order, and you'll receive your fortune.
Wait, what?
This?
You proceed through the pipe next door, looks like you have a great meal sometime in the future.
I like meals.
Green pipe?
Yay!
Oh, Yoshi cook.
A great meal?
Hmm?
Ah!
Hello, Tile.
We'll get you to the next room, your fortune determines which room you'll arrive at.
If you're lucky, you'll run into Bellum, and Monstro Town will just be beyond him.
Alright, I'm not accepting visitors past my bedtime.
I like meals.
Give me the key, and I'll let you pass through.
Wait, what key?
Senpai, what key?
Where's the food?
I have to do the fortune again?
The fortune...
Last time
Oh, hi again
You look tasty, I think I'll have a snack
So what am I supposed to do like do I hit
Do I give him a Yoshi cookie
Oh, he's not a puzzle, okay
How do I switch, switch some people? Oh, yeah
I'll switch you, Alziboo
Oh
Her or a flash can't block. Okay, that's not bad. Wait
I
Can never forget his taste in fact after one slurp I can clone someone watch
You look delicious, but how do you taste? Oh?
I got sour
There we are
Oh
Oh shit
Does it work on people who are
Or
No
Yeah counter-impulsive
It would you a totalist this
Stargust
Oh
It's cute how if like Mario is like incapacitated he just uh
He just throws a plush time to go home for dinner. Bye boys and girls. Oh, he just leaves
He just leaves and I'm just like oh, I just wanted food. Oh
Hello again, the pipe is sure cuts in my home Moscow town you there
Okay, oh
How cute oh
It's like a long line
Oh
Careful setting freeze
Just
Last
Oh my
I'll travel from afar welcome to monster town where many monsters mingle and the landlady monster mama
Oh
You're here to see our star she's upstairs, so feel free to go and take a look for yourself, okay?
I mean all around the world the strangest person I miss this old easter-in-roads town. He's really weird, but definitely worth meeting
Sometimes if you jump at the right place a treasure box will pop out of thin air. You like that happen to you
Your box are known as hidden treasures because they appear out of nowhere
You think you found them all but still but you still have 39 hidden treasures left wait really
So cute
Look at the hip sway
I'm not gonna lie to you my mind. What do you think isn't our star adorable? Actually? Yeah, she's so talented to folks come to see her from afar
Garbies all star piece no no not familiar with them
So you come all the way and search for a star piece must be really important the last place on land if you can't find it
Here the only places left is up
Oh
So you want to go there you're an open book. Okay. Here's what you need to do. There's a secret passage
Sky at Ween Valley first you must scale the cliff beyond the desert to get there
That's such a nice guy. I want you to see to someone that can help you
Our troopers. I need you
What was our flying time troops
8.5 2 seconds sir sergeant
Our troopers reporting for duty ma'am. We are 0.52 seconds late. I'll hold myself personally accountable for the delay ma'am
It was riches as ever about your rules and regulations. Don't need to worry father about protocol around me sergeant
I've got a favor to ask of you. Yes ma'am anything we can do for a civilian
This fellow here really wants to get the beam valley to help him scale the cliff
Understood ma'am orders are getting a stash over the cliff. We will succeed
We will not deploy ourselves to the cliff at land's end. Our troopers keep a tight formation
We have liftoff
They're odd but trustworthy good luck with your search
Is there a random like
Hidden chest somewhere
There's none. I'll see any at the center of the table
Here
Oh
Cute
Oh super jump is your specialty, right? Well multiple jumps of yours are pretty amazing
I heard that your record for consecutive jump stands at 13. How do you do it?
You have at least 30 in a row and I'll give you a prize
What?
Oh, there's a thwomp
Ah
You there Roman has is your quite an accomplished jumper
Really weird sometimes I hear the guy next door. I was mumbling about a crystal this and evil that
Some kind of shiny rock or something. No, I've seen those somewhere
It has been sealed
Shiny rock you say okay, okay, I know you're all giving me hints, but I have a memory of a goldfish right now. Yes
Just a minute. I'll be there in a second
Oh my
Gumiura like gumiura. What are you doing here a bowser spinny?
Just, huh?
Uh, sorry about going a long you I ran away because I was scared of to fight smithy
What has happened and but look how far I've come I'm managing the story now
I
Look where we are
My little ones come on show your manners and greet uncle bowser
Oh, I can't fight for you I have some items you can use maybe you'll find it in your heart to forgive me if I can
Help you get equipped
All right, I'm not angry with you got new minions now. I'm looking to her cleaning my castle
You go on with your life here. I wish you the best
I get you
I'll probably get some cleansing juice party cleanse
Spike chomp
Herd shell
I
Have to can we play free can we?
You have to please can we
Let's see what's with these mushrooms
I buy from each kid
I
Sell back those weird mushrooms
I can sell my old weapons for cash
I
Only one way to find out why they're weird are they I swear
Wait, do I bring it back to the the guy?
This go free to rest here three musty fears
Uh-huh
Nice to meet you. I'm creeper. I'm boob and I'm drive homes
Where are the three musty fears?
He's sleeping
Boy sure he is he sure is got those bubbles coming out of his nose
Maybe you can still hear us while he's asleep. Hey you
We want you to we want to play around and find the flag
Right well each hide a flag somewhere around the world
I
Not three flags and you get an awesome prize
We'll go and hide the flags you when we get back
I'll be back
I'm back. I hit my flag behind a wooden flower. Oh wooden flower
I
Home my flag is under a green bed
You never get my spot it's between all and a our flags are invisible so search very carefully you think you found the right spot
All in a
Like the letter
Hey well and good morning
Thanks for coming by
This
Oh, I haven't I haven't you know I haven't uh
Why you know
Explored yet lose that sorry, but the census isn't in oh my gosh
Gager
Bowser I haven't seen you for so long and studying here at the doge under
Sensei jinx because to tell you the truth. I I knew I couldn't beat smithy
That's why I'm here now someday. I'm gonna return and make you proud
Don't worry about me
I've got new minis now. We're gonna take back my castle. You stick to your guns train like there's no tomorrow
He's so kind
He sensei's out right now, but he'll be back shortly. In the meantime. Will you accept a challenge for me? Sure
Great, you know, I'm not gonna make it easy for you, right?
Well, oh shit
Oh
Yikes, you're tough
Yikes, I guess that was to be expected mario here top notch fighter you did well for your inexperienced you
Jagger
Oh tiny thing
Sensei have you been here all along?
Hmm you felt my key didn't you bad for a novice
Fighting style isn't as foolproof as you think
I'll accept the challenge any day
Just to challenge me sure. All right, let's see what you're capable of
Oh, he's so fast
I jump on you
I
Get a little bit
Snowy
Ah
Resistant
Oh
Goodbye mario
He's too strong
Oh
Just kill me already
You know you get like seven
Oh
Yes beach
You know I do like six
He's too small oh shit
Well
Phew simply amazing wait what
Yes, I underestimated you packed quite a punch don't like it do you go to head because I let you have that round. Let's have a rematch
Later how did I won how did I win?
Where's my need the room where I can go to sleep again I go to sleep again
You
When in flower
That's you me up
You
Strong silent type, huh?
Don't you dig these vibes yeah
I'm talking to the thwomp and it does not working
I'm gonna go outside. That's it. Oh shit
Tempo key. Oh the key from before
Or
The key from before don't film out there
Back
Well give me the loot room now
Gotta redo the tongue
You
Swung
You have there looks pretty tasty
Yeah loot
We're rich we have money
How do I get out of here
You
But don't do I have to fight him again
Do I have to fight him again
I was like for a second there. It's like if he's harder I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna cry. I'm gonna cry. I don't know if this is like, you know, you know pokemon where they they like yeah
You know like in pokemon where you can rematch people and I'm like, that's nice to know
Shiny rock, huh
In a green bed
Had pulp on
I
Don't remember how to do this
Hey, I'm not
Can you repeat that again? Hold on. Can you repeat that again?
Okay, second and third line is dull
Ray me
She
Hold on let's go back to monster town. They totally can't recognize that sound very well
Music I don't know my like notes, you know
Hello
You
Hold on I'm gonna take a picture of this physically on my phone
Because I'm stupid
Say cheese you
Because I am not musically inclined
So I my mind is not good music
And they said a shiny rock. I'm thinking about evil. I'll grab that soon, too
Oh
I can't fucking do it
I
Hold on first one is this between the second that one
That's something composed well, that's not the right melody wait what?
Wait what
No, I follow the thingy to the t right
I
The tune wait what?
In the picture
What if I go backwards
I
Monster town sorry fine. Give me a second
Fine
Write it down
Okay, this one is me
You
Ah
Ray
Wait, did I get the wrong one shit
I think I messed up
I
Hold on let's try this again
That's dough, okay, hold on
Oh
Ah
Okay, let's try this again. I'm stupid I'm stupid music hard
I
No, I'm so stupid. I don't know where me is
Oh
Ray me
La
Okay, I wrote the other one which is
Me me do so do re latido
Oh
That's me
Dole
I
No, that's not right, so far, E, oh, okay, second line, okay, go again,
okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
Wait, where am I? Wait, I lost track of where I am.
Where am I?
Okay, hold on, go, go, T, la, okay, T, wait, did I miss one?
Oh shit, I missed one, I missed one, fuck!
I'm sorry.
What did I miss? What, where, here, I was, me, do, so, do, me, do, so, do, day, fuck, I was out of day.
This is me, right?
Needle.
So, what was the line? Okay.
Okay, I'm at Do, okay, this one's Ray, which means I'm at La, right?
Wait, was that the right note? Shit.
Okay, I'm at Do, okay, this one's Ray, which means I'm at Do, okay, this one's Ray, which means I'm at La, right?
Ah! Ah!
This is what it feels like, oh my gosh.
Okay, well, so, so, Ray, Ray?
Okay, that's it, this is the melody I've been looking for, thank you for the inspiration.
He's taking this as a token of my gratitude, a tenner card.
Any need help with my composition again, I'll look for you here. Until then, adieu!
Oh my gosh, I'm so bad at notes, I'm gonna save, save that again.
At this point, I'm about to learn so much music, oh thank you for the super chat, Jackson Shaw, hi, I'm new here, glad to finally catch you, thank you!
Oh, that monster town star dances too, oh thank goodness!
What?
Is it, is, better be the fucking same one as the chart.
Better be the fucking one as the chart. If it's the same one as the chart, it'll be okay.
What?
Yes, that's it, this is the melody I've been looking for, thank you for the inspiration.
He's taking this as a token of my gratitude, a soprano card.
Finally, my song is nearly complete, I confess, you contributed a lot to it, so we cannot take credit for it.
Now you must think of a final phrase that will wrap it all up, let your creative juices flow and show me what you got.
Wait, do I just, do I just, uh, do I just, just make a song now, Senpai?
Okay, here we go, let's do this, it's our song.
Huh?
I can't believe I wasn't beeping boops! What do you think? Let's hear it again!
Yeah! That was great.
Nevermind, that was great. E that way, shut up! We did it! We did it!
Would it sound different if I recompose it?
Your composition is pretty good, thank you. Greatest composer of our time, Merciel.
I'm winking, but you can't tell.
I think my ending was pretty good. Wooden flower, right?
Did Rosetown have a wooden flower?
Yeah!
Wooden flower, uh, green bed, huh?
Where is the green bed?
Is it my house?
Mollyo's house have green beds?
Okay, this is green.
Hell yeah, look at that! I'm so fucking smart!
What's ONA, though? Between ONA? ONA, don't call.
Was there a place with ONA?
ONA, were there letters in places?
Is it the ship? Is it the fucking ship?
I don't want to go back to the sunken ship. Not the ship, okay, good.
Marymore?
Do we have letters anywhere?
I'm trying to remember a place that had any letters.
And they said a shiny rock here, right?
ONA.
I'm gonna feel a little silly when I come across it.
Don't tell me it's the fucking title screen, right?
It's not my house again, is it?
It's not my house again. There's an ONA in my house.
ONA!
The Yostar Island?
Are there letters here?
What the fuck? I'm so good! I'm a fucking god!
I'm a fucking god of this! Wow, easy!
How do you feel, Senpai? Your life is a god of puzzles!
I did it! I did it, I did it!
Now give me cool stuff.
Good job, you found all three flags!
Hey, you're not half bad. You did pretty well.
And a great time too, thanks for playing our game!
And a grand prize giveaway!
Very well, and good morning!
What did I get?
Okay, what did I get? Did I get a level up or something?
Massure?
Ghost medal! Double's defense! There we go!
And I need...
There's still this evil that...
There's still...
I'm so fucking smart though.
I was like, where's this very silly place for it to be?
It's like I need to remember places that had words.
Crystal.
Are we talking about the moleville?
Wait, the shiny stone!
Oh, money!
Money!
My money!
Better fucking be worth it, man!
Look, the shiny stone is reacting! See how it's been broken!
What is this?
Wait, huh?
Greetings. I am Kulex, Dark Knight of Vanda.
I've crossed into this dimension to fight the Dark Maid.
You look like you're from a fucking different game!
You who stand before me, where does your death come from?
Why are you rendered so three-dimensionally?
The evil power that gave me life mapped out this flat plain as my form.
You were formed from a power unknown to me.
I wish to gain the secret of your three-dimensional world!
Will you enter combat against me?
You're wise to hesitate. Without any weapons or armor, you have no chance.
I guess I'll try again.
Yeah!
Wait! Who are you from?
Are you from Final Fantasy? I've never played Final Fantasy!
I am Anti-Matter. I can see your past.
I can see your future.
I consume time.
And I will consume you.
I can see your future.
Ow!
Ow! Wait! Why is there a dog star? Ow!
I can see your future.
That's the super boss!
Oh, what do I do with this... this rock now?
What do I do with this rock now?
Now I have a chenny rock!
Just hold on to it! Do I?
Alright then, um...
Can we trade it?
Wait, is rain? Oh wait, rain? Do you like Final Fantasy?
I can't remember who wanted the shiny stone!
Use the stone to open the door! Wait, is my stone gone then?
MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
I can't remember how I'm supposed to get to a new place, right? Here?
Hmm? You wouldn't want to give it away anyway, Colhite. You did the last stream and got one item, so it was a waste of money. Just hold on to it until you face the boss again.
Okay. Okay.
Oh, fuck.
It's always you guys.
Oh! Heart Beach!
Oh, that was really strong, actually! Stupid wolf trap.
Oh, look at that! I blocked it! Wow! I missed that one, though.
Fuck.
Let's go!
Hi, Colhite. I've been lurking, but I should say something to let you know I'm around.
Have I ever told you? I always want to make that joke like, be there or be square because you're not around.
Wow, I am bad.
I can make these jumps.
Goodbye.
Oh, Bowser leveled up! Bowser!
He's a cool.
He's a cool. Whoa!
Is it... pretty close, I think.
Is it this one over here?
No, I don't think it's this one, right? It has to be the one there.
Wait, this game is actually so cute. It's my mommy! Everybody say hi, mommy!
It's actually too addictive. This might be a problem, Senpai, because I signed up for yoga tomorrow!
Yeah! You win!
Get him! Get him again!
Oh!
So... here?
Fuck you. I'm not doing this again.
Yeah.
Does this feel like another path area?
Tell them about the clip we are getting of you from this game. Wait, what? Wait, there's a clip?
Wait, there's a clip?
Oh, the clip where you can't jump in the sea!
I remember that!
Wait, there's more over here.
Oh, troops in position. Mario, your mission is to scale the cliff by jumping shell to shell.
Don't give up. Sure, instead he does it now. Try it again.
No!
No, no!
Wait, it didn't punish me as much!
Never mind.
Did I mention platforming hard?
No!
Yeah! Yes! Yes!
Mission complete! Elapsed is 24. Shut up!
Not bad for a civilian. Shut up. Let me out of here.
Do it faster for an item? A what item?
Okay, where am I supposed to go? Bean Valley. Okay.
I hate flowers and I hate these, these, these, these Conti flowers!
Don't be a Conti flower!
Okay, jump!
I mean welcome raiders! Now I actually see someone!
Welcome my me! Hello raiders, welcome to the stream! Oh, he flowers love.
How's Mario RPG? Um, I am always suffering.
Wait. Shit.
Attack! Fuck!
I didn't turn into a mushroom!
The pet's in there.
You recover? Not for long!
Flower! Oops, I meant flower, no?
Oops.
I hit the wrong button, that was my bad.
Oi. Oi.
In the last! Woo!
Get shroomed! The way there's no shrooms here.
Die. Stingy flowers.
How dare you recover! Better not be a Conti flower when I get back. It seems to be a Conti flower.
Should I start putting things into attack, into magic now? Or should it just all be attack?
Attack. Magic!
Yeah! Oh, that's cute. You know, get to level up. You get your magic.
Okay, I guess it's over here, huh? What do I have to do here? Do I sneak by them?
It looks like you're having a good time.
What do I do? Am I supposed to fight them?
Crippid!
I need more maple syrup.
Wait, shit.
Man. Okay, it's awake now.
No, Gino, last them!
Oh, shit. EW!
And now the way it moved is almost so gross!
EW!
Gross.
Yo, yo, yo, girl! Disgusting, disgusting, the way you move is gross!
Let's just kill it like this. They're really cute like this. Wee! Look how cute they are! Look at the star!
Really? I did nothing?
Oh, thank goodness.
Friendship is not strong enough. What am I supposed to do? Am I supposed to wait for all these? Oh, I can enter it.
Oh, I got something.
Guess I fight all of them.
Okay, good thing that's normal then.
What the hell?
Oh, it's fast, at least.
Yo, beach!
I'm gonna just kill all of them.
Oh, frog coin! Yay!
Now you're okay!
Okay, now what's this?
Did that give me cool stuff?
Oh, well, that was quick.
Is there anything here? It's not cool?
Easy money, okay. Come on, start flowering! Just start watering! I need to kill some bitches!
Come on, start watering! Just watering! Water!
Wait, I need to go in here.
Is this name please, no? That's so cute.
What the hell is that? Genie was inside?
Well, power friendship, hopefully. No, no power friendship. Actually, switch you out.
I want the power of not friendship!
Another one! Well, that was kind of rude, wasn't it?
Okay, better fucking level up a lot! Oh, I got like 150 coins though. Yay! Coins!
Okay, now start watering!
Start watering!
I don't want that flower thing to move, it's disgusting the way it moves.
Oh! Fuck you!
Ah, fuck!
Come on, Peach, start reviving things!
Ah!
Why is this taking so damn long?
Oh, come on, I don't have anything!
Can I switch him with a dead body?
Oh shit, I forgot to use the thing!
Wow!
I need therapy!
That's so fucking rude though.
Ah, fuck you!
Okay, if I move.
Yeah!
Oh, these guys!
I like this thing.
Okay, Mario!
Ooh, stop! Yeah!
What?
Yay! Magic!
Magic!
Look at all them, like, leveling up! I think that's one good thing.
Okay, last one!
Yeah! Fuck yeah!
Oh look, I got watered!
Yay! I got a frog coin!
Look at that, I defeated everything!
We are now super strong! Get over here!
There's more!
It's shower time!
There they are, my pretties!
Oh, dolly-dum!
There's two of them now.
There they are, my pretties!
Oh, dolly-dum!
Lottie doll, really?
And some nutrients!
There they are, my pretties!
Phew!
Oh, I turned into mushroom!
I'm in here!
Wow!
Where's mine?
Oh shit.
Oh, hi! Can you do anything?
Yeah!
What you did?
Oh, I'm gonna get it!
Queen Valentina told me to keep everyone out of Nimbus Land!
Should I do?
I know, I'll run away!
What's this? The seed, take it.
Pick up the seed.
What's this?
Is this like, you know...
Oh, did you see that? It's like a magical beanstalk!
Get the block one more time to climb it!
Yeah, like, jack-in-the-beanstalk, okay.
Whee!
How to climb vines.
Climb and circle around the vines with L.
Jump to another vine by tilting L in the direction you want to go and pressing V.
The shadow below as your guide, Nimbus Department of Transportation.
Can I talk to this? No.
Talking not an option.
Look at the big chonker!
Fuck.
You guys ready to launch?
He's so cute!
Does he do, like, really big damage, though?
Oh, what was it again?
Oh, I just...
Uh-huh
Wait what?
What?
Oh
I miss it's cuz he's so high
Get bitch let's go let's go
Oh like I go like this
What's this platform for is it just wait what's the platform for wait what's the platform for
Hmm
Oh
Fuck
Another one over here
Whoa
I'm bad
Like it
Yay just throw stuff at them cute
Oh
What now you know what to do
What's this
I
Kind of want that though whatever that was
Ah
Please
Just let me grind on the block
Wait
Is he on there he's kind of stupid. Oh yay
Ow
Oh
I got the timing for that finally
Aw man
Oh
That was not good platforming
I hate platforming you know what this game
Game hard that form hard
Oh
I'm not gonna say anything
Fuck
That's so mean
I get the big one
Now I have no choice
I have no choice but to like climb on to that platform. Otherwise I'm gonna hit it
Fuck
Ah
Why is this so hard to do I hate things that like are hard
Oh, it's so it's like look at the shadows
I
This is so hard. This is so difficult senpai. I need your encouragement your moral guidance
I think it's the same angle as the blue vine
Oh, I can't I can barely make it
I
Difficult springy vines that look like
Oh
This is like this is so platforming hard by the way
I
Why why why can't I reach it?
Why I I I I this is so difficult to do I
Why is mario hard marios mario is not a real game. It doesn't require skills
I read that from like some some reddit poll post and I said
Wow shit
Perspective what are those
Anyways, this game's like it's like pulse like that where I'm like yeah, I guess I'm not a real gamer
Oh
Why why do you just jump jump jump
Hold on I'm putting on my my glasses
Maybe you can help me with the
Why
I let's know
Oh
Was it this hard in the original senpai those who played the original have you
I think I was way harder
You think that they fix it, huh
Please mario
I'm begging you
My hands are getting sweaty
Oh
You like that was close
We
Dang it I was hoping I would like take a shortcut for that
Hey, maybe if I'm just like directly at it nope
What
Difference would it make to be on the floating path platform though, isn't it the same like blank?
Sorry for asking dumb questions, but like isn't it the same distance need the height okay
I
Not to go left
Well, am I supposed to go though
Go straight like sorry confusing down left like like how I'm I'm here
Like this like that position. Yeah, okay
Oh
You got the defense scarf I want a scarf
Do I fall through here now
Oh
Don't hello hold on let me check defense scarf
Do raises defense power
Wait
Right the popcorns let's bring her up ahead, but only royalty can bathe her and you don't look like royalty
Let's bring her up ahead
Me going yeah
Jumps over them
Hot springs
This one
Oh, this is the map the nimbus land. Okay got it
Where's where's the parents?
Oh, this is nimbus land all right everyone listen up
Shut up
She's so she's so
Boing boing
King nimbus is conditions growing worse this means we'll be losing our magnificent ruler
But it still happens I found the missing prince prince mallow that is prince mallow, please
Sir prince
Get over here
Oh
Seems our little prince has a mild case of strange fright excuse me
I'm making snappy. What you can't make it through through why am I not surprised?
That
Doesn't look like good prince
Introducing prince mallow
I'll come back prince. You've grown prince. You can fit prince
Yeah, what is it dear?
What you're asking me to
Gracious you're serious, aren't you? I don't know what to say
Dear me
I made a decision at the request of the prince. I agreed to become his queen
Queen valentina. Oh, it just makes me shiver
Well, that's it back to your business everyone
Great up. Well, yeah
You believe it what there's a prince with the same name as me
Only have anything better to do than hang around here. Come on. Let's go and find the rest of the star pieces
He's a prince. That's me
Wonder why more people from the world down under don't visit us these days. I hope it's nothing personal
Nothing personal kid
I think you like the guards. We have the other interest now. I don't used to have them
This mallow that huge well, she says it must be him. So it must be him
Where's the king would get well, but at least the prince is back. Just in case something awful happens
You know, I was just a suffrage mallow. He's changed, but yes, I do believe that's him
Our king nimbus appears to be a tad under the weather
I
Have a smell make Valentina his queen because she found him
Well, let's go into these places
Can't believe Australians don't visit Johnny. I want Johnny to visit
Hey, you had the I'm looking for something on your looking your eyes. What can I do for you?
I
Mega gloves sticky glove
Cannon war fan
These any good fluffy shirt of your pants, fluffy cake, fluffy dress
Yeah, sure
Oh
Sorry, excuse me. I need to I need to um, I need to to to go crazy for for for for uh
my my uh
Made of honor. Thank you
Wait, do they know me do they know me do I have to introduce myself again?
Thank you, holy west for one mom
Oh
My gosh
I love you
We know but go ahead. Hi, my name is
Mercy. No, sorry. My name is
Marcio, Marcio
What a welcome to the stream inside it's a fun time to be here. Yeah
We are playing the Mario RPG
Yeah
It's Garo the sculptor's place to make all kinds of things for king to miss these days king isn't calling for much new art and being sick and all
It's a me
Wait, that sounded more like
Wow, why Luigi's it's a me
Marcio is feeling in oh, hey, hey look, it's me
Oh, you mean that that's king miss when he was a young lad
Oh, uh, huh
What the who are you?
Hi, my name is mal
This is my friend mario
Oh, so it's you my boy. It's been so long
I've become a splendid young prince
But I I'm really a prince
Oh, oh charades time
Wait, you can do that now your charades has gotten so much better
Mario your your charades gotten so much better what the heck
Yes, indeed. I understand you're raised by the frog sage
There's no question about it. You are without a doubt prince malo
Like it used to be like
And now it's shape-shifting
Hi, y'all look at me. I'm a prince
I knew Valentina was up to something. I just didn't know what
That must mean that the king isn't gravely ill. Let's go inside the castle and say my mother and father
I'll get him later. Hey, you are you you can't just barge in here
Oh, he walked back
Wait, I have an excellent idea come over here
Are you ready? Yeah, no, no, no, hang on. Okay, just say what okay now
Oh still okay
There hey, don't move. I mean statue for a while. Okay
You're going now
I'm delivering Valentina's latest order to her you may enter
All two girls there
Don't look like Valentina at all
Oh, it's a statue of Valentina's nephew ma
Mariota, okay
Oh, okay proceed
Next next you're gonna tell us mercy ill can transform to mercy modis
Um
Yo, I was close didn't think we could get through that one. There's no such person named Mari
Mariota ha ha
Oh
Oh now, okay, I need to change the voice give me a second
Oh now this is lovely my beauty simply shines forth like the sun
Only you can make something this stunning
Thank you your majesty. I'll be on my way now
halt
What may I ask is this ugly thing
That's my latest message beat I created it just for you. It's called uh in search of lost brother
Observe the thick moustache with it. I depict his kind feelings for his younger brother
And the sideburns conveying his strength of heart
The legs well defined strong legs that can leap any distance in a single bound
to your liking
Hmm, I consider myself something of an art buff and I've got to say this is spectacular
Girl only you could have created sculptures with such gentle beauty and raw power
Thank you your majesty. Thank you your majesty. I'll be on my way now
Oh
spectacular
Dodo Dodo don't sit there like a rose. I can carry these in
Dodo
Step on it
Oh, he does not like her
Oh
The the old joes the old joe laugh is pretty good
Yay
No, for some reason I'm getting dizzy or maybe some reflection reflectiveness
Am I there a cage there Dodo
Display the statue properly fine now polish them into a fine luster and make them a tribute to my beauty
Pay attention to me. Hurry up and don't let me catch you dozing again. Oh, she just liked me for real for real
Uh-oh Dodo's in a pretty bad mood keep up your statue disguise and jump to avoid getting pecked
Get ready because he's coming this way
Oh
Oops
What the statue was ticklish that what you said try stalling one more time. I'm gonna have your feathers plucked for my pillow now scat
Oh
Fuck
Don't bother me if you're so worried why don't you go give it a good back?
Oh
Shit
Sorry senpai at the end stream soon
I signed up for yoga and it really early in the morning
So let's beat this real quick
I
Sign up for yoga
My friends were like, please if we have lots of people we can get a discount
I said okay
I am so out of it right now
Have you done yoga much before I've never actually taken a yoga class
Oh
We're back to a full health that's nice
Give me a second
Okay, I think this is a good spot to say yeah
Yeah
Yeah, I'm two stars left. I think we're pretty close senpai
Looks like we have looks like
One more move left at level what level are we?
At level 18 so one more
No four hours of you have tonight. Nope. Sorry. Sorry. Let me just move to just chatting right now
I think you're not working anymore hold on deep mode
Oh
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. I oh no, who is it?
It's no longer mercy y'all now it's me mercy
It's gonna be my first time doing yoga as a class and in general
Where do you never see mercy on mercy in the same room? Wow
It's amazing. It's so interesting. My chat isn't working either. That always happens. Anyways
Oh
Oh, this is the wrong tweeter
Okay, there it is so
Uh tomorrow is the last stream of the week, uh and the stream is wild arm
So
Wild arms is uh
I will be playing it once again as a reminder
I'll be playing it on the original ps2. I have a physical copy
So I am not emulating it, but it looks great. It looks great. So we'll be playing on original hardware
I
Played it uh last week and then we're gonna continue uh wild arms again. So yeah
It's gonna be really fun. Um, I don't think this game is available anywhere
Except for the physical copy. I don't even think it's on
um
I don't even think it's on like
The sony playstation store is it?
So I'll be playing uh ultra code f
We'll be playing on the ultra code f so please uh
Hop in join join take a look at a game. That's kind of rare
Um, what else what else? I'll be posting my the rest of my uh
next week schedule uh sometime tomorrow as well
and
well
lba full week uh that week compared to this week, which was kind of like uh
Not that many streams. So I hope uh
You you are will enjoy next week's schedule as well. I want to announce
each that the following week after next week
From the 8th to 14th, I will be gone on vacation
Yeah
So I'll be gone on vacation um
A bunch of my friends have been like oh my gosh
Congrats on the new job. We haven't seen you in forever. Let's hang out and I figured
Now would be a great time since I haven't really had a vacation in a while
I haven't had a vacation in a while and so
I think uh, we're just heading out heading out. Um, maybe I think we might be going camping
I'm not sure. I'm leaving the itinerary to my friends to the girls
Ha ha
So, whoa, whoa
I'll I'll come back and see my supplies after my little recoup your recuperation period
So that's from the 8th to 14th
Mm-hmm
So the itinerary is up to them, so we'll do it and then
Yeah, hopefully I'll have the energy a lot of energy tomorrow. I am streaming
As I said like today I streamed an hour earlier than I usually do
Because I made a mistake on my schedule
And I think that next week was I I actually haven't had enough time to to test out this this time
So I want to see if
Uh, we'll test this time
Onto into the next week as well. And if it works out great
This will be our regular time if it doesn't really work out if I feel more exhausted or I feel like it's not really good
um
I'll
Move it back to the old one first impressions on this time slot
Because it's an hour
earlier
I have to get home earlier
Then I then I
Expected so it makes me feel a little rushed
Makes me feel tiny bit itty bitty a little rush
But it's still pretty late
It's still pretty late, so it's not too bad, but you know like a nine. You're just like oh well
No rush I can just get home
Right, but now it's a little bit a little bit like of a rush
But I feel like a lot of people can catch me catch me more
but
We'll see we'll see we'll see
Senpai
Thank you
Omadon for the
669 or 10 a that australian doors noise wait
noise
My lunch money for senpai. Thank you for your lunch money
Maybe we can find the middle ground whatever works best for you
I feel like if starting on the hour makes people more aware of this get more aware of the schedule unwilling to
To make a little bit more time, but yeah, uh this week was my mistake. I uh
I put it in the wrong
Wrong
Wrong time slot so
So that was my my bad my bad, but we're gonna test it out so far. I feel like senpais are a bit happier
You like senpais are a bit happier, so that's real good
That's really good. I'm so sorry. I had to cut this short. I did agree to be like yeah, I'll do yoga
Early in the morning
But yeah, uh, we'll continue wild arms and mario rpg as well in the upcoming week
That's not on the schedule, but it will be there
Uh
Anything else to say, uh, uh for light comers. I am now
Uh anything else to say, uh, uh for light comers. I am now
Uh, what's the word I have a code
For gamer subs use mercy for 10 off your gamer subs order
If you use my code a lot we might be able to get
You might be able to get my few cups and maybe a flavor
So that is that is where but we're at remember to use game resets code six times because all
Because all of the uh
All of the girls from vealer have
Have codes so remember to order six times and use the code six times
I actually never tried a um a powdered energy drink before so but uh
My my gen mates management and strawney say it's pretty good. It's pretty good
I heard it's pretty good. I I don't really drink energy drinks. I I've had like a monster here and there
but
This would be my first time trying like a powdered one. So I'll see how it goes
Uh, I got kindly sent a pr package. So maybe there's a hand cam in the future
Maybe
I I I don't really drink energy drinks. So
I'm I'm hoping I'm hoping that
That maybe I'll I'll really like it. They sent me three interesting flavors. I'd like to try it out
So
I like the raid's d sound when you say colds because it sounds like colds wait
Wait, do I say it like that? Wait
Wait a second. Wait. Wait now. I'm getting so conscious about the way I say things
cold
Cold
Now I'm getting self conscious about it. No
No
Sometimes
Sometimes sometimes I'm uh, I say things I say things a little funny. I say things a little funny. It's okay
I can't believe it. I can't believe I'm getting getting caught caught saying funny saying things in funny ways
Ha
Don't worry same ish. I struggle with the word perseverance
Perseverance perseverance perseverance perseverance
Perseverance, I think I say that normally
I know there's some things that people are like, oh you can't say that funny
And I'm just like no no you're lying to me say mountain
Mountain
English is my fourth language. That's why I was able to catch it. Wow. Don't clock my accent
Ha, that's really impressive though. Congratulations on learning four languages. I only know
Two and a half
No, it's more like one and two of them are are like a half and like a quarter
Now say wash your shots
What's the half the first half is Vietnamese
The second one is
Like the quarter one is like Japanese
And like there's like one that's like itty-bitty
tiny tiny
Like not even super impressive at all is like french
Which I am I have like such, uh, such, uh, what do you call it? Um
Precious like understanding a french. What words do you know in french?
Not enough to like speak it but enough to like be like I can read that
Yeah
I'm let do from hush
Well, hi, can you say wolf
Like regular wolf or like in french
It's probably not
I don't think I know it in french. I like I said, I know like a facetious
I know I'm from my french teacher was this formula bush like shut your mouth
Have her neck is very cool back thing french french never use it, right?
Right, which is why I'm just like yeah, it's like the facetious like
Um
Wait facetious is like fake
Hold on. Let's look at the facetious
facetious treating serious issues with deliberately inappropriate humor are flippant
Isn't tavernak and it started something it's like saying shit
Or fuck
So that's your word of the day
It's called hi very flippant. I wouldn't know if I would call myself flippant
I wouldn't call myself flippant probably not
But I would say like my my my uh
Knowledge of languages is not that great
Like so so so very tiny. I don't even think it would count as learning a language, right?
Or knowing a language it would be count as like, you know some words and that's it
I
Think uh
Yeah, I really greatly respect people who know a lot of languages. I have trouble learning languages
um
But learning languages is a little easier when you're surrounded by people in that language
And therefore you can speak you can speak it at any time
You can understand English outside of American accents at least right but I understand sort of sort of
If if it's like really really heavy slang
I might I might have trouble I might have trouble if it's uh
Uh if it's like really heavy slang like if
If you know people start saying saying weird things
The ant translate about newfoundland slang
Oh, she's all there. She got a couple wheels on her. Yeah
Ha ha ha ha ha
Other than coli coli coli coli coli coli will comes you understand stronti, right? Yeah. Yeah, I understand stronti quite well
Can you say
What the fuck did I just say am I gonna get banned?
Hello quill. There we go. Wait. I need to say colloquial. Yeah, there we go colloquial. Wow words
I love you in tecala. Okay good. I'm just like
I'm just like
I'm just like, um
Yeah, I didn't say anything weird, right?
I didn't say anything weird that's a bannable offense, right? I'm gonna get bonked, right?
My accent is probably really bad. I mean my accent in all languages is pretty bad
Like
I think
My accent in vietnamese is very much very foreigner like
and my accent in japanese is very
also
foreigner like
It's cuter though slightly cuter. I don't know why I say where's the japanese slightly cuter
Hahaha
Slightly
Because I'm always cute wink. Wait. Anyways
Before I start yapping my head off. I really have to go
Anyways, I know I'm so tempted to get yab yab yab yab yab
But I really I I gotta wake up. I gotta wake up. It's it's an early thing
It's an early early early, uh
It's an early, um
I was gonna say stream. Wow brain rot. It's an early
Class and so I have to be there. It's a little bit. It's a little bit far away too. So it's a bit of a drive
Oh, yeah, let's go
Thank you for joining me today some pies and others who are new here
So
I'll see you again tomorrow for wild arms. I hope you all join me for wild arms. I think wild arms is pretty
Cool. Yeah, cool. And it'll be my first time playing it. I'll be playing it
Blind with uh with maybe some help from some some pies. Yeah
Yeah, okay. Okay. Okay. I'll see you again tomorrow. Mwah. Okay. Okay screen for mercy
Let's go
So